bien mes chers collègues nous allons
donc ouvrir la séance nous poursuivons
donc le cycle de nos auditions avec
aujourd'hui monsieur le directeur
général de la sas
monsieur dominique mara nani qui on
irait si je prononce bien parce que
c'est parfait candidat et madame
fabienne bartoli qui est donc adjointe
au directeur général de l'afssaps
et alors je prie d'excuser vous avez
fait tout ce qui était en votre pouvoir
pour arriver après madame la rapporteure
mais ça n'a pas été suffisant puisque
elle n'est pas encore là je suis
absolument désolé mais elle va venir
dans plus de temps et ça ne nous empêche
pas de commencer cette séance si vous
n'y voyez pas d'inconvénient
d'autant plus que je vais d'abord des
formalités suit vous rappeler d'abord
que cette audition est ouverte à la
presse et fait l'objet d'un
enregistrement en vue de sa diffusion
sur le site internet du sénat et
éventuellement eu de public sénat je
vous demanderai donc mais c'est vraiment
formel puisque cette audition publique
et vous avez eu l'occasion monsieur marc
nesme qui de nous indiquer
lors de la séance de la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat à laquelle je
participais d'ailleurs que depuis cinq
ans vous n'aviez aucun lien d'intérêt et
j'imagine que madame bartoli dans n'a
jamais eu un compte tenu de ses
activités professionnelles
elle n'intéresse pas a priori les
laboratoires parce que sur sur ce
pictures sur ce plan là en tout cas mais
vous avez quand même été longtemps à
l'industrie je crois pas du tout n'avait
pas exercé des responsabilités où il
sert l'industrie donc pas du tout alors
c'est parce que j'ai une biographie
alors qu'il correspond pas on le dit
conseiller technique pour les industries
de santé au cabinet oui d'accord oui
celui de chargé d'études à la direction
politique industrielle et d'innovation
oui à la cie doute sous direction des
multi sectorielle direction de la
prévision et de l'analyse économique au
ministère d'économie et de gestion au
ministère mais pas en cabinet au
ministère s était pas de ministère
l'industrie puisque c'est l'actuelle
direction générale du trésor et de la
politique économique d'aujourd'hui non
qu'il attend du ministre de l'économie
et des finances est donc pas du ministre
de l'industrie
hier écouté puisque c'est ces questions
sont donc réglés nous allons tout de
suite entré dans l'utah d'abord
qu'est-ce qu'une question oui j'avais
donné un certain nombre de documents
bref effectivement bon alors j'en aurai
pas nécessairement besoin aujourd'hui
enfin ce qui m'étonne c'est que un
document que je vous ai demandé et qui
est vous n'arrivez pas à le trouver
alors ça ça demande quand l'application
il s'agit de du rapport du centre
régional de pharmacovigilance de
besançon franche comté sur les zones
arides et l'hypertension artérielle qui
a été communiquée lors de la réunion de
la commission nationale de
pharmacovigilance du 10 mai 94
alors vous ne l'avez pas trouvé mais est
ce qu'il existe
alors écoutez dans les archives il n'est
pas présent à redemander suite à votre
demande de la semaine dernière donc
justement au centre régional de
pharmacovigilance de besançon ce rapport
qui n'ont pas en leur possession
il n'est pas versé dans les plusieurs
fois de rendre les nombreux cartons
d'archivés qui sont à l'argent en
revanche on à l'étude sur et l'étude
peut-être de 98 de quatre-vingt quinze
15 qui avait été dirigée par monsieur
ben ali allons ce seuil elie baup est hs
et c'est autre chose mais on n'a pas ce
qui m'intéressait justement c'est que
d'ailleurs gelé
je pourrais vous le passé mais joliment
6 une amie non mais je parle de celui
que vous avez demandé à khor abéché
parfait jeu formidablement vous avez
réussi à aller au travail sur les
cheveux bas c'est merveilleux mais non
la question plutôt comment se fait-il
que ce document disparu ouais c'est ça
le problème c'est pas tellement de
problèmes que je laissais surtout
comment est ce qui est inquiétant c'est
que justement il parle du médiateur
c'est ça qui est qui qui met qui
m'inquiète un peu je me dis bon est ce
que c'est moi qui vais un peu qu'ils qui
fantasment à peu mais c'est quand la
première fois qu'on nous cite des cas
c'est en 94 des cas où une association
isoméride plus médiateur provoque des
hypertensions artérielles
or comme par hasard ce document on peut
pas se le procurer
donc tient effectivement aux personnes
qui étaient responsables de la wii belle
je n'arrête pas de poser cette question
si vous voulez mais il ya beaucoup de
questions d'ailleurs qui restent sans
réponse sur et 1 c on est assez déçu
d'ailleurs par cette enquête que nous
menons quoi on trouve rarement des gens
qui nous disent oui par exemple le
médiateur demande à des personnes très
compétentes un jeu demande par exemple
un monsieur à monsieur le professeur à
benhaim quand est ce que vous avez
entendu parler du médiateur
en 2009 a au moment où il a été supprimé
jamais alors j'avais avant et je cite le
cas bon je cite par exemple monsieur
monsieur ou monsieur un de vos
prédécesseurs monsieur tabuteau qui
était donc directeur général dans 95 et
là je suis en possession d'une note par
exemple d'une note qui ne figurent pas
d'ailleurs dans les dents les wii dans
les annexes du rapport je sais pas
pourquoi des rats de même que lors ce
rapport ci ne figurent pas non plus dans
les annexes du rapport et et dans cette
note
on parle bien du médiator en tout le
temps parle pas de l'influent ils sont
dix médiator c'est au moment où vous
savez où on a supprimé le on a interdit
les préparations magistrales contenant
du benfluorex et c'est à cette occasion
qu'on a bien identifié le bal furax
comme étant le médiator était conscient
à cette époque que le médiator était sur
le marché et qu'on interdise et les
préparations magistrales mais pas les
préparations pharmaceutiques
alors là aussi bon monsieur tabuteau que
nous avons interrogés à l'époque je
n'avais pas cette note à ce moment là a
indiqué je vérifierai sur le compte
rendu mais je ne me souviens pas qu'il
met dit que à l'époque il avait
connaissance du médiator oui alors tout
ça c'est je dirais que je c'est
préoccupant en connaissent mais voilà
alors si ça vous intéresse cette note je
pourrais vous la remettre si vous le
souhaitez voilà et si par hasard vous
aviez dans vos archives des notices sont
susceptibles d'intéresser je vous serais
très très très reconnaissant de bien
vouloir nous les adresser sens que j'ai
besoin de vous les demander merci donc
nous allons passer refaire que vous
voulez vous pouvez soit on passe
directement question bien alors vous
vous faites une intervention liminaire
de
du temps que ces congrès les questions
alors là pour serait alors la question
d'abord je voudrais vous poser c'est on
va diviser sangs purs
d'abord celle qui concerne
l'organisation l'émission elle
financement de l'afssaps a estimé vous
comme le révèle le rapport de l'igas que
notre jeu si tu as police du médicament
a failli à sa mission et je cite
d'autant plus ces termes qu'ils ont été
repris in extenso pain monsieur le
ministre xavier bertrand dans son
allocution lors de la remise du rapport
ça c'est la première question vous
voulez que je vous pose plusieurs
questions où vous répondez plusieurs
d'accord la deuxième c'est êtes-vous
d'accord avec les inspecteurs de l'igas
horses écrit dans le rapport je cite
encore de manière plus globale
l'afssaps qui est une agence de sécurité
sanitaire se trouve à l'heure actuelle
structurellement et culturellement dans
une situation de conflit d'intérêts pas
en raison de son financement de sa
parenté une taxe parafiscale mais par
une coopération institutionnelle avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui aboutit
et ça c'est très grave me semble utile à
une forme de coproduction des expertises
et des décisions qui en découlent ainsi
la page 14 du rapport
une troisième question alors qu'il
s'adresse peut-être plus spécialement à
madame bartoli à propos de la gestion
des conflits d'intérêts vous avez
indiqué au télégramme de brest me
semble-t-il c'était le 17 février 2011
mais vous les tenez beaucoup
d'interviews a du mal à s'y retrouver
enfin je pense que c'est le télégramme
de brest peu importe que je cite les
règles sont les mêmes dans tous les pays
européens
alors nous nous sommes nous y sommes
allés voir et nous a semblé que les
règles en vigueur notamment en droit yom
unis n'étaient pas les mêmes que celles
qui prévalaient
l'afssaps sur un poids particulier qui
nous paraît très très important qui est
celui de l'indépendance des experts au
mhr à les experts qui donne la vie sur
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
n'ont aucun lien d'intérêt sera pas de
conflit ils n'ont aucun lien d'intérêt
donc saint tite une différence me
semble-t-il fondamentale et qui invalide
un peu ce que vous avez déclaré alors
peut-être que voulez vous expliquer
peut-être que quand vous avez quand vous
avec l'affairé pour moi alors je pense
que je pense au contraire moi qu'on
devrait pouvoir s'inspirer de cet
exemple avec profit il ya une quatrième
question qui s'adresse encore à vous
madame par tollé vous avez des classes
et cette fois ci au journal au journal
la croix
le 26 octobre dernier nous avons une
règle intangible
les présidents de nos commissions aux
groupes de travail ne peuvent avoir de
liens durables avec l'industrie à
travers par exemple la poste de
consultant c'est un conflit et levé qui
a priori nous conduit aussi à juger
comme contre indiquer la présence d'un
expert au sein d'un groupe de travail
alors je voudrais que vous puissiez
m'assurer que les présidents et vice
présidents des commissions des mêmes et
des multiples et multiples groupes de
travail n'ont pas non pas des des liens
d'intérêt de ce type avec l'industrie 1
cc bon alors je cite comme exemple mais
c'est hulk a maintenant mais monsieur
par exemple
je prendrai sur le chat qui inquiète
actuellement directeur de l'évaluation a
été longtemps directeur du groupe
thrombose alors qu'il avait des liens
très important avec le le laboratoire
sanofi aventis montrouge
j'estime tout à fait normal que les
médecins travaillent avec laboratoire au
contraire reims et c'est bien pour eux
et c'est bien pour l amour mais quand il
s'agit de prendre des décisions pour le
compte de l'état alors là j'estime que
on ne peut pas accepter ça alors je
voudrais que vous essayez de me répondre
à ses quatre premières questions 1
nous avons prévu une quarantaine alors
assez d'être bref on fait une deuxième
séance peut être mais je vous en prie
par rapport aux commentaires sur
l'organisation les missions de
financement de l'inca et le constat ou
le commentaire que l'un cap là car
excusez-moi l'afssaps excusez moi je
penche manger vient d'une autre maison
où vais je ne fais la passe est-ce que
l'afssaps a failli à sa mission mais la
réponse est oui
la réponse est oui mais on ne peut pas
ne peut pas dire que ce qui s'est passé
avec médiator ne souligne pas les
faiblesses du système de l'afssaps je
crois qu'il ya un consensus qui est
générale au niveau des parlementaires de
la société y compris à l'inter de
l'afssaps donc la question pour moi qui
prends cette responsabilité nouvelle c
est qu est ce qu a failli et comment
peut-on faire pour que cela ne se
reproduise plus et ça c'est un devoir
qui doit guider notre réflexion dans le
futur vous participez bien sûr votre
analyse de détail et de la situation à
nous donner
bon les pistes pour y arriver je vais
vous donner un simplement mon point de
vue naïf
bien que de responsables sur un des
aspects du du médiateur notre travail le
travail de l'afssaps et d'assurer la
sécurité sanitaire et la sécurité des
produits de santé et l'équité leur
distribution à partir de la remise en
question du bénéfice et des risques que
peuvent avoir des médicaments des
produits de santé
à mon sens pour le futur la leçon à
tirer est clair c'est à dire que ce ce
système ne doit pas être
c'est instable c'est dans une ambiance
dynamique on doit réexaminer les
bénéfices et des risques
nous étions dans un système et nous
restons peut-être dans lequel il faut
prouver qu'il est grise que terrible
avant de remettre en question l'intérêt
d'un médicament
or un médicament qui n'a pas beaucoup de
bénéfices a par nature beaucoup de
risques et notre travail notre
responsabilité devant les parlementaires
et devant l'état c'est de peser cette
balance bénéfices risques et ça doit se
faire autour du temps et quand voit
l'histoire médiator dont je ne suis pas
expert mais bien évidemment je vous ai
écouté et j'ai lu on n'a pas réexaminé
prenant beaucoup débattu sur les risques
on a très peu examiner des bénéfices au
cours du temps c'est ma première leçon
la seconde c'est au tour du rapport de
aussi de l'igas et ça va aller
qu'est-ce que vous avez mentionné sur l'
expertise indépendante
c'est à lagence de questionner les
experts et par vous experts d'inspirer
lagence un exemple autour du médiator
quelles que soient les experts
extérieurs
si au fil du temps on s'était interrogée
sur la molécule mère que vous connaissez
bien et mieux que moi sur la nature
pharmacologique de cette molécule on
aurait pu constater qu'il s'agissait
d'un anorexigène finalement de la
famille des amphétamines
bon il s'agit pas d'une vue globale
c'est une vue analytique
la deuxième question qu'on aurait pu
poser c'est est ce que une amphétamine
fait maigrir la réponse est oui
est-ce que de maigrir c'est diminuer la
tolérance au glucose la réponse est oui
c'est ça diminue la tolérance lipides à
la réponse est oui c'est tout ce qu'on
les experts à dire mais ça ne fait pas
un médicament antidiabétique ni anti
hypercholestérolémie donc de juger les
bénéfices oui monsieur le même sénateur
tant fait la pluie et le beau temps dans
cette auguste institution dit encore
aujourd'hui que le boeuf le rec ce n'est
pas un art of orexigen mais un
antidiabétique mal étudiés alors il est
évident que quand on lit par ailleurs
c'est que je suis indiqué tout à l'heure
dans le le rapport igas mais on est bien
obligé de constater que les thèses et
rooney du laboratoire et bien ont été
prises comme argent comptant par
l'afssaps agence du médicament l'époque
un don qui a là un véritable problème
donc l'incapacité pour l' agence de
développer disons une analyse autonome
original face aux laboratoires
j'espère que ça a changé j'en suis pas
absolument sûr je sais en tout cas que
ça changera ça doit changer parce que
cette histoire ne doit plus se
reproduire
ça va avec la problématique de
l'expertisé externe versus interne
c'est en interne que nos pharmacologue
doivent analyser la nature
pharmacologique de la molécule quand je
dis questionner c'est pas questionner la
firme s'est questionné dès qu'un des
experts externes confirmeront module
euros ou infirme euros d'autre part ce
qui était peut-être vrai en termes
d'analysé pour le responsable de
l'évaluation dans les années 80 puis 90
n'a plus lieu d'être dans les années
2000 dans la mesure où le sujet c'est la
prise en charge des personnes atteintes
de diabète ou d'hypercholestérolémie
pour lesquels il ya d'autres
alternatives thérapeutiques
donc il me semble en tout le simplicité
que c'est le devoir de la gent si elle
prend la responsabilité d'une de
distribuer des médicaments sur la base
d'une relation bénéfice risque de poser
elle même les questions et pas qu'aux
jeunes et pas attendre d'avoir la preuve
qui est des événements indésirables
effroyable
la preuve qu'il ya des événements
indésirables effroyable
avant de remettre en question l'utilité
est donc la distribution d'un médicament
c'est ce qu'on attend d'une agence alors
c'était pas très facile avec
l'organisation c'est pas très facile
avec les contraintes réglementaires
auxquels ont été soumises l'agencé vous
avez manifestement illustrait que notre
travail c'est de garantir les bénéfices
pour les patients et de limiter les
risques pour les patients et donc à une
certaine époque ça peut être le cas puis
ça ne m'est plus dans la suite
et personnellement je pense que c'est la
principale faille qui devait l agence
n'a pas déployé son expertise et sa
neutralité dans l' expertise par rapport
à l'objet qu'elle avait à traiter celui
ci comme d'autres et dans le cas de mes
responsabilités je tâcherai de dirt
inversée ce processus pour nous-mêmes
questionner et je voudrais que les
parlementaires le sache mais vous je
sais que vous le savez ce questionnement
doit être itératif ça a évolué au cours
du temps les connaissances d'accord la
relation bénéfice risque ça a évolué au
cours du temps parce qu'on a plus de
connaissances par contre la chasse à la
preuve du risque ou l'imputabilité d'un
risque est une chasse qui ne se fait pas
dans le bain dans le cas du bénéfice
pour les patients éventuellement pour
ceux qui cherchent des formulations sa
complication mais ce ne doit pas être
notre travail
oui lisait vous êtes donc par principe
hostile 7
cette disposition qui a été d'ailleurs
transposer dans notre droit de la
directive de 2004 qui prévoit qu' on ne
réexaminera plus comme par le passé tous
les cinq ans le rapport bénéfice/risque
vers la haye mêmes voyous on va
réexaminer le médicament cinq ans après
sa vie sur le marché après c'est pour la
vie c'est fini
non mais on peut continuer on a le
devoir de continuer à suivre le bénéfice
et le risque de ce médicament
on peut rien on n'est peut-être pas
soumis dans le cas de la directive un
réexamen de l'air de deux là et même par
contre si les agences font leur travail
de suivi ils peuvent eux même déclenchée
ces guides qui sont soumis à des
obligations de réévaluation parce que on
se cacheront parce que on a le devoir
éventuellement de remettre en question
avant cinq ans si on pense qu'il ya des
risques qu'elles aient risques qui sont
trop importantes et c'est toute la
notion qui va arriver à partir de 2012
qui veulent le suivi global qui s'impose
à tous les médicaments avec des dates
périodique mais une mm c'est pas
forcément définitif et surtout le
contenu de là mêmes qui n'est pas que
l'autorisation de la mission marché
c'est à dire les indications et les
contre-indications par nature doivent
être adaptées et moduler au fil du temps
et au fil des connaissances et au fil
des des observations pour éviter la
deuxième une des deuxièmes plus
nombreuses de la sphère du médiator ce
qu'on appelait l'utilisation aura est
même déjà dans le cadre de l'indication
c'est est discutable mais en dehors de
l'indication non seulement c'est
discutable c'est catastrophique
donc si les agences qui assure de la
sécurité ne réexamine pas le bénéfice
risque dans une indication correct qui
peut au fil du temps se restreindre ou
s'élargir dans la dans l'intérêt des
patients
on sera toujours dans un système aveugle
et on attendra que les complications
catastrophique pour
des donneurs d'alert éventuellement
corriger le tir donc on doit le corriger
plus tôt et ça fait partie d'un travail
régulier
c'est toujours désagréable d'avoir un
réexaminée régulièrement des dossiers
mais ça fait partie de la vie de l'accès
à l'innovation
mais ça c'était sur ce point des accords
du futur la problématique de la
coproduction voilà où la critique sur la
coproduction coproduction là je suis
réservé par rapport à cette remarque
tels que qu'elle est présente est bien
sûr dans la globalité du rapport de
l'igas je la comprends mais c'est une
présentation qui telle qu'elle peut
paraître quand même un peu une vision où
je qualifierais un peu polémique
est ce que les agences du médicaments
des produits santé doit avoir des
relations avec des industriels que la
réponse est oui
la réponse est oui elles doivent les
avoirs taux de façon à anticiper ne pas
supporter elles doivent donner aux
industriels la règle du développement
c'est à dire quelles sont les attentes
médicale et sociale que la france ou
l'europe attend d'un médicament innovant
dans le cadre du diabète ou du cancer
donc elle donne les règles du jeu
ensuite elle vérifie sur des faits ce
qu'on appelle le dossier que sur la
relation bénéfice du risque par rapport
à cette règle du jeu attendu est
bénéfique et là on rentre dans
l'indépendance totale c'est à dire que
la font la force de l'alloeu de l'agent
ce qui peut-être pas assez déployer ou
du moins pas assez commenté y compris
dans le rapport de l'igas
que ça se passe en france en europe et
aux etats-unis puisque le processus est
le même c'est de donner l'autorisation
en vérifiant dossier et avoir la
capacité d'inspection et de contrôle
j'insiste sur ce point leur esprit de
responsabilité dans ma fonction c'est
évidemment sur les capable d'inspecter
et de contrôler et qu'on ne suis pas que
des allégations
est ce que vous estimez que si une
réforme vous permettait de disposer
d'unités pharmacologique qui vous
permettraient quelquefois de contrôler
un certain nombre d'essais concernant
certains laboratoires certains
médicaments pardon parce que les essais
qui vous sont financées par l'industrie
qui vous sont proposés par l'industrie
bis q jusqu'à présent vous n'avez que ça
à votre disposition pour vous déterminé
lors de la mise sur le marché
est-ce que vous sort vous utiliseriez
cette possibilité et de d'avoir recours
à une instance indépendante pour
vérifier que les essais thérapeutiques
les essais cliniques prêt à et même des
laboratoires sauts sont valides ou bien
et 7
cette unité pour aussi être utilisé pour
les examens post inscriptions bien
entendu il va il va de soi qu'il est de
la responsabilité de la fable ou de lin
mun de levier de toute agence qui donne
une autorisation d'avoir les moyens de
vérifier que la donne sur des faits et
donc il faut qu'elle garde sa capacité
des inspections de contrôle qui existent
bien l'afssaps vous avez acteurs
l'impossibilité de faire des essais à
bien sûr de vérifier les essais de faire
d'eux les audits et de vérifier si des
données fausses normand dans mon travail
en plus rien faire des essais on peut
refaire des poules et vous le faites
quelquefois l'afssaps a autorité n'a pas
encore les moyens
l'afssaps a suscité des et c'est bien
celui-là ça ne doit pas être promoteur
wc il faut bien voir ce public soit
promoteur donc c'est généralement
l'hôpital public qui assure la promotion
au sens réglementaire 2
oui mais je sais que je vais dans la
situation où vous avez des doutes sur
sur tel médicament un tel médicament
soit empreint même soir post m
alors vous avez la possibilité en prêt à
et même très clairement ce que nous
devons faire c'est vérifier la qualité
des essais et c'est un travail compliqué
puisqu'il faut aller éventuellement
jusqu'au données sources
il ya des techniques nous le faisons
mais pas assez d'accord vu la quantité d
et qui sont soumis
mais l'alliance européenne qui se fait
dans le cadre de l'om à donne une force
de frappe qui est meilleur qui n'est pas
assez utilisé pour le faut le
reconnaître pour vérifier ces données
sources des essais éviter évidemment
qu'il est fausse interprétation
deuxièmement poste inscriptions nous
devons avoir les moyens
alors c'est pas une agence ça n'est pas
mon but c'est notre responsabilité de
vérifier d'inspecter de contrôle et aux
three lions ne contrôle pas on risque de
se faire avoir dans notre appréciation
et ils vous stimuler des études dites
post a est même d'accord elles ont
besoin d'être stimulée elles ont besoin
de stimuler avec des promoteurs publics
et pas des promoteurs industriels
il me pose la question la réponse est
oui mais voilà c'est très clair et nous
en avons probablement si les agences as
aussi mieux dans le cas d'une politique
un peu complète sur médicaments il n'est
pas dit non nous aurons tous besoin de
ressources supplémentaires mais il n'est
pas dit que des ressources mieux
affectés à cette problématique puisse ne
pas être déployés le fonds du programme
hospitalier de recherche clinique
cher à financer beaucoup d'essais
cliniques très fréquemment poste à mêmes
composés exclusivement posta mêmes
heureusement la question c'est que telle
est notre capacité à intégrer les
résultats de ces essais allaient suivre
et elle est donnée pour modifier nos
pratiques et nos connaissances il est
clair que nos demandes faire et il faut
qu'on soit un peu plus incisif l'afssaps
a donnent l'autorisation de réaliser des
essais cliniques qu'ils soient
académiques industriels
c'est à dire qu'elle est capable de les
interdire mais la faf doit pouvoir
regarder un peu plus quel est le
déroulement des essais les interrompre
l'austin eux n'ont pas des incluant
suffisante et doit pouvoir aussi demandé
à leurs promoteurs y compris
universitaire académique des résultats
précoce qui permettrait pour des raisons
de santé publique d'orienter la bonne
pratique du médicament c'est la richesse
de notre système
elle n'est pas assez déployés en terme
d'autorité donc c'est un vrai champ
nouveau qui nous devrait nous permettre
de mieux maîtriser avec l'argent public
et nous aidons ne pas subir en fait
uniquement des études
allez disons la vérité il ya beaucoup
d'études dit une poste inscriptions qui
sont des études marketing alors que ce
devrait être des études d'implémentation
dans le système de santé pour mieux
comprendre
seriez vous connais tu qui sont jamais
ri à 10 heures mais celle là il faut les
interrompre et les sanctionner
il n'y a pas de sentiment il ya des
sanctions mais sont impliqués il ya
juste un port jack sanction qui a été
envisagée puis qui a été annulé après
contact ac laboratoire donc elle jamais
eu de sanction alors il a besoin dans
les sanctionne pas les laboratoires sont
des débats comme vous le savez sur le
médicament dans la vraie vie par rapport
à l'essai clinique d'enregistrement
cieux je voudrais insister sur un point
la majorité des essais cliniques en
comme limite d'âge de recrutement 75 ans
or la majorité des personnes qui
consomment des médicaments souvent en
plus de 75 euros
donc nous nous pouvons peser sur les
firmes de ce qu'elles font des essais ou
sur les promoteurs académique pour qu il
s'inclut des personnes qui ont besoin de
médicaments dans la vraie vie et pour
que nous anticipions sur les risques et
bénéfices dans chez ces personnes là qui
vont être soumises à ces médicaments
sans que les forcément des données
suffisantes les concernant si tu me
gossin grèce où les poser une question
profitez-en
oui merci monsieur le président vous
parlez beaucoup du contrôle en amont
dans la chaîne du médicament
et que pensez-vous du système
aujourd'hui et des moyens aujourd'hui
alloués aux médicaments vétérinaires
parce que l' agence du médicament
vétérinaire feu l'afssa s'appuyait
énormément sur le laboratoire qui était
juste à côté où c'étaient des
fonctionnaires aussi je me rappelle
avoir en tant que toxicologue réaliser
des essais de contrôle à la demande de
l'agencé du médicament vétérinaire je me
rappelle aussi avoir accueilli une fois
une délégation de l'afssaps qui venaient
voir comment est ce que l'on faisait sur
le médicament vétérinaire pour contrôler
la pureté des vaccins par exemple donc
pourquoi ce système là n'est-il pas en
place au sein de l'afssaps
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de son
éventuelle mise en place c'est quand
même beaucoup plus intéressant en plus
très en amont de s'intéresser notamment
à la formule chimique aux îlots mer etc
d'une molécule notamment quand on pense
au médiator et à comment dire tout le
brouillard qui entoure effectivement sa
composition chimique le déconcentration
des métabolites et c'est dans votre
marque et bien sûr pertinent que je
répondais à la question jurassienne à
40,1 sur le contrôle des essais
cliniques
leurs anticipations leur suivi leur
contrôle et éventuellement leur
interruption lorsqu'ils ne répondent pas
aux critères évidemment deuxième
fonctions d'inspection et de contrôle
qui peut se faire sur les produits
d'accord c'est ce que vous vous référez
qui est quand même réalisé par l'afssaps
nom de dans pas mal de domaines
à l'échelle nationale et aussi à
l'échelle internationale c'est à dire
qu'en partenariat avec d'autres agences
qui contrôlent des morceaux de la chaîne
du médicament pour ça vous a pas échappé
pour les maladies virales pour l'épauler
vaccins nous aurons à réfléchir sur
notre sur les moyens dont nous disposons
c'est très clair pour assurer une très
bonne qualité de contrôle avec les
nouveaux produits qui se présentent
l'enjeu de ce début de xxième siècle se
situe beaucoup autour de produits issus
de la biologie et des biotechnologies
avec l'arrivée de bios et me similaires
et la manière de contrôler ces produits
suppose de pratiquement d'avoir une
capacité de l'éco développer ou d'être
capable de maîtriser un certain de
techniques très sophistiquées qui existe
très peu dans nos laboratoires et nous
aurons investir en france et ou le
partager avec avec d'autres pays sans ça
nous allons supporter finalement des
dossiers que aider des produits que nous
pour lesquelles notre capacité de
vérification sera limité donc c'est un
enjeu à venir de sécurité de contrôler
et de nouveaux produits dans les
présentations dont les formes dont les
bénéfices mais aussi les risques dans la
chaîne de production et aussi dans le
rapport
présentation de la molécule sont de
nature différente des produits que nous
avons connu dans le cas c'est ça aussi
c'est ce que j'appelle la dynamique
qu'il faut savoir s'adapter aux produits
qui vont arriver que notre capacité
d'inspection ne soit pas trop ancrées et
de contrôle sur les techniques qui reste
encore importante en chine mais basique
mais qu'elle est un peu au delà en
matière de biologie votre question sur
donc c'est pas de coproduction non c'est
pas de coproduction c'est chacun de son
côté mais pour être bon de son côté il
faut avoir une capacité intellectuelle
et des compétences en laboratoire qui
permettent de répondre
aussi enfin ou de questionner de façon
pertinente l'affirmait être capables de
la contrôler ça existe franchement
l'afssaps et c'est pour ça que je
rassure cette responsabilité il est
indiscutable qu'il faudra le développer
à propos de la gestion des conflits
d'intérêts et de l'indépendance des
experts
je voudrais marquer ma propre il faut
sortir de cette histoire de façon
définitive le quand je suis arrivé à la
table ce n'était pas très inquiet car
les intérêts étaient au moins déclarés
est dans l'ensemble assez bien géré mais
avec assez de fermeté et d'autorité donc
il est du rôle de des responsables de la
sat qui ne sont pas complices d'imposer
les règles et de faire disparaître ou
sortir toute personne ayant un lien
d'intérêt qui nuit à la capacité de
l'indépendance de l'expertisé nous ne
pouvons plus supporter collectivement
que ce soit dans ces domaines ou dans
ceux de l'environnement ou autres la
remise en question permanente de l'
expertise et je partage vos pour votre
point de vue la bonne réponse est pas de
liens d'intérêts du tout je voudrais
qu'on dise aussi quand même par rapport
aux présidents de commission les
fonctions des différents prise de que
responsable de président de commission
présidente commission président
commission da et même pharmacovigilance
ce n'est pas tout à fait pareil que de
participer à un groupe de travail ou du
président et en groupe de travail
comme vous l'avez vu en angleterre dans
un groupe de travail soit on laisse le
groupe de travail faire le travail de
l'agent et là c'est grave pas même s'il
est composée de bons des experts parce
qu'ils auront forcément des conflits
d'intérêts voire même des intérêts
personnels sur une manière de traiter
les maladies ce sujet
que vous êtes capable de venir combien
vous avez deux commissions de groupes de
travail
ben oui nous l'avons rapporté mais on
pourra que vous leur préciser parlera
par écrit c'est tout à fait ce que c'est
le détail si c'est considérable course
et je crois que je crois que nous avons
un talent à épier le julian ans m la
notion de groupe de travail et parfois
sur est surestimée et surestiment air et
parfois surestimé il est normal que
quand rassemble des personnes un appel
c'est un groupe de travail
mais ce groupe de travail mais
éventuellement se réunir une fois par an
pour donner un avis haddock sur un petit
support sur un petit sujet ce qui compte
pour le futur près clairement c'est
qu'ils aient pas d'accumulation de
groupes de travail et que surtout on est
ainsi l'otage des questions comment ce
oui mais c'est pas c'est pas grave on
parle pas du medic jean médicaments
c'est beaucoup moins que la mienne me
répondre de façon beaucoup plus précise
puisque les connaît par coeur question
je suis posée donc c'est une excellente
peut-être transit transition va falloir
tellement donc pour les groupes de
travail qui sont rattachés à la
commission d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché en a 31 d'entre eux
oui bien sûr mais pour répondre à votre
question de façon précise il ya douze
commission à l'agencé mais qui concerne
l'ensemble des chais du domaine de champ
de compétences c'est-à-dire les
médicaments les produits cosmétiques les
biocides les stupéfiants les dispositifs
médicaux bien sûr donc c'était pour
répondre aux questions gestion sur le
média manger ou les médicaments on est à
31 12 12 12 ans 12 12 s'élançant des
commissions où il ya dispositif local
cosmétiques produits biocides commission
nationale des stupéfiants pour les
médicaments de trois grosses commissions
voit la commission donc enfin
covigilance à mêmes et puis la publicité
quoi exactement
assez d'accord très bien alors cette
parenthèse étant fermés
mais les questions que j'ai posées
concernant awilo le bas oui ce que
comment voyez-vous les expertises quoi
puisque vous indiquer que la salle
finalement les experts sont traités
comme dans toutes les autres agences
alors ce qui m'a parce qu'il est apparu
faux est ce exact
alors c'est très difficile monsieur le
président de vous répondre sur un
extrait de citations qui ne me
correspond pas à l'ensemble de
l'interview j'ai nommé par ailleurs
comme vous le savez vous-mêmes sans
doute pour donner parfois des interviews
on n'a pas toujours la jambe on n'a pas
toujours forcément la liberté de relire
exactement les propos qu'on vous de
cancon vous attribue ne sont pas
toujours forcément exact donc faudrait
geler sous les yeux pour vous répondre
en revanche je peux vous répondre sur le
deuxième point
voilà si ça peut sur le deuxième point
sur lequel vous ne m'avez interrogé sur
l'interview que j'avais donnée à ce que
ces vos citations
alors moi je vous renverrai à mes
sources qui sont les documents que nous
mettons en ligne et que nous contrôlons
sur le site de l'afssaps car je sais que
vous êtes toujours vous allez des
dossiers très complets on avait fait un
point presse oui je sais pas plus
complet que les vôtres moi ces gens bien
ce que je souligne monsieur monsieur le
président est donc je reviens pour vous
répondre précisément pour que l'on
puisse avancer sur les quarante
questions donc vous m'interrogez sur la
présence de liens durables notamment
pour les présidents des groupes de
travail et des commissions et donc lors
de ce point presse que nous avions
réalisé en 2009
je vous dise pas de bêtises non même 30
mars 2010 même pour être très précis
nous avions repris l'historique de la
façon dont les conflits d'intérêts sont
gérés de façon pratique aux pratiques à
lagence et en particulier sur ce point
donc mon avis on avait bien précisé que
c'est à partir de fin 2006 que l' agence
à renforcer ses exigences d'indépendance
liés à la fonction de président de
commission et de groupes de travail et à
généraliser la pratique de l'appel
public à candidatures pour donc pouvoir
recruter les fameux experts qui serait
présidents et membres de ces groupes de
travail et de ses commissions
et d'une sélection par un jury en vue du
renouvellement des membres des
commissions et groupes de travail et
dans un souci de transparence et
d'élargissement du recrutement et c'est
à partir de ce moment là justement que
on a demandé aux présidents des groupes
de travail de ne plus avoir de liens
durables donc je pense que ce que vous
mentionnez comme exemple est antérieur à
2006 voilà précisément le bruit alors
mais où je pense
il ya aussi un problème de deux
permanences je pense que rester pendant
12 ans 13 ans 15 ans président d'une
commission
et c'est pas c'est pas une bonne chose
or qu'est-ce qui se passe
puis alors rien n'y a plus assez que je
me suis aperçu en lisant vous plaît pas
l'âme bartoli que mon agence ne
respectent pas la réglementation puisque
vous avez donc en février à 2011 ses
récents adressé une lettre où je verrai
obligé de constater que jusqu'à cette
date
la famille vous écrivez la récente
publication du rapport de l'igas sur le
rôle prochaine l'apsap ce enfin comme
quoi les crises etc c'est utile dans le
deuxième éditeur ainsi que nombreux
débats publics ont remis en question la
présence des représentants du lem au
sein des différentes commissions et
groupes de travail de lagence cette
présence apparaît en effet comme
incompatible avec une obligation et une
garantie d'indépendance des avis donnés
par ces commissions groupes s'en est
jamais trop tard pour s'apercevoir mois
ya déjà des années que que je que je
mène ce combat alors que vous étiez
d'ailleurs avec votre ministre à
l'époque monsieur bertrand et je me
faisais en rien dans le mur
régulièrement parce qu'on prêt pour un
farfelu
enfin je suis très heureux à que vous
arriviez à sem constatations j'en suis
très très très heureux alors en ce qui
concerne la commission d'autorisation de
mise sur le marché
l'article r 5100 la têt à 54 du code de
la santé publique qui fixe la
composition ne prévoit pas de
représentant de notre organisme
professionnel a effectivement une lettre
que vous arrivez hall m et pourtant ils
étaient là donc pour quelle raison ce
que l'afssaps ne respectait pas la
réglementation est ce que c'était le
seul domaine où elle ne
respectez pas cette réglementation alors
effectivement vous leur demandez bien
gentiment que de bien vouloir quitter
ces commissions vous vous comportez
remarquablement bien vis-à-vis de
l'industrie pharmaceutique et c'est tout
à fait normal d'ailleurs à mais ce que
je comprends pas c'est que ces gens-là
se soit retrouvé au sein de commissions
alors qu'il n'y avait pas leur place et
voit pas bien sûr ceci je cet exposé des
motifs la question alors que c'est que
s'est il passé
pourquoi cette situation je vous écoute
alors de façon très simple comme vous
l'avez bien si tu essaies la
réglementation est donc cette
réglementation une dépend du ministère
de la santé et pour préciser les choses
en fait la présence de l'organisme
professionnel est bien prévu dans le
texte qui régit la commission
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
mais avec une voix non délibérative et
donc c'est à ce motif effectivement
qu'on peut demander à l'organisme
professionnel de ne plus être présent
lors de cette commission sans pour
autant entachée d'illégalité tout vote
de ladite commission de m avant que le
ministère le ministre lui-même prennent
les mesures qu'il jugera utiles à
prendre pour régir l'ensemble de ces
commissions donc l'afssaps en résumé
n'était pas du tout hors de la
réglementation puisqu'il est prévu dans
ce texte une présence non délibérative
de l'organisme professionnel pour autant
comme c'est une présence non
délibérative effectivement en février
2011 nous avons souhaité que le lem
puisse ne plus être présent donc si je
si je résume
vous pensez que la présence dans les
commissions que ce soit titre
délibératif comme c'est le cas par
exemple de la commission de la
transparence puisque je viens il sont la
réglementation prévoit en tout cas leur
présence à leur présence à la commission
de transparence
alors quand la commission à mm je suis
vous dites que je
il ya un texte qui prévoit que à la
commission d'un mêmes mais à la
commission de nationale 2 fun de
pharmacovigilance là je suis tout à fait
d'accord
la présence est donc prévue par la
réglementation à la commission de la
transparence aussi mais je ne savais pas
que la réglementation prévoyait la
présence de da représentant de
l'industrie pharmaceutique avec voix
délibérative
je savais pas non non je viens dire avec
moi non non des livres qui racontent est
bien d'accord je ne savais pas mais
enfin on apprend tous les jours donc
vous êtes allé si j'ai bien compris que
cette lettre au delà de la
réglementation et vous estimez que nous
devons donc continuer dans ce sens là
c'est à dire modifier la réglementation
pour que les industries pharmaceutique
n'est plus de représentation au sein de
ces commissions
je crois que du tout ce qui s'est passé
de notre responsabilité directe nous
avons voulu rapidement modifier le
fonctionnement de la commission d'amm et
même de façon à le rendre plus
transparent dont les ordres du jour sont
publiés sur le site parce que la
transparence est meilleur lorsqu'on
connaît l'ordre du jour des sujets qui
vont être discutés deuxièmement toutes
les interventions sont intégralement
retranscrite
ce qui pose pas de difficulté dans une
assemblée comme celle ci ils peuvent
être consultés sur le net à distante de
la commission troisièmement je veille
personnellement
à la déclaration des conflits d'intérêts
qui sont affichées en début de séance
c'est à dire tous les membres de la
commission connaissent tous les intérêts
des membres de la commission qui l'ont
déclarée dans les cinq ans à venir et le
responsable de l'afssaps publie et
affiche les personnes qui seraient
susceptibles d'avoir un conflit
d'intérêt mineur ou majeur et le publie
devant tout le monde
façon à ce que les choses soient que
soient claires enfin pour éviter la
suspicion de pression de l'industrie
pharmaceutique fabienne a demandé à la
chambre patronale du thriller mystique
qui chez g avec one hand et behra titres
comme prévu par les textes de se retirer
une remarque sur ce sujet l'app donc les
prochaines réunions
la commission la prochaine sera filmé en
plus les débats seront accessibles sur
le net
sur la partie délibérative nous aurons
des invités et les invités seront pas
pour tous les sujets mais pour les
sujets qui les concernent des
associations de patients de façon à pas
leur imposer ça c'est l'état nos voeux
pour le futur c'est que s'il a dû si la
chambre de l'industrie représentait il
faudrait c'est en tant que partie
prenante mais à ce moment là il faudra
que d'autres parties prenantes qui soit
présente comme les professionnels de la
prescription tout de même comme ceux qui
distribuent les médicaments les
pharmaciens d'officine comme des
associations de patients quand même et
de consommateurs ce qui importe à mon
sens c'est que le regard soient claires
et que personne ne puisse douter de
l'est de l'équité des débats et que les
dossiers soient accessibles et que quand
c'est nécessaire
et çà doit on doit pouvoir le susciter
les réunions doivent être rendus publics
c'est pas une innovation non ce n'est
pas une innovation mais il suffit de
voir là mais il faut le foot mais il
faut le pratiquer donc la prochaine
séance
la semaine prochaine sera sera public et
ceux qui s'expriment et par contre est
dès maintenant tout le monde peut
vérifier par la présence donc des des
firmes industrielles dans leur
représentation patronale à mon avis a
pas lieu d'être
les firmes sont audités par la
commission en cas de besoin cc by son
être elles sont audités et elles sont
chacune de leur parti je crois que c'est
très important de la suspicion et si je
peux permettre monsieur le président
peut faire un voeu sur les évolutions de
la réglementation sur les commissions
est très important que les commissions
que tout ne soit pas dans une seule
commission de la fda et même afin que
les commissions haddock qui permettent
de traiter des dossiers très importants
pour la santé publique mais pas très
intéressant dans la relation bénéfice
risque comme les dossiers de génériques
comme les dossiers de reconnaissance
mutuelle car vous verrez si vous
regardez nos ordres du jour que deux
heures du jour pourrait pas être noyés
par tout un flux de dossiers pour
lesquels en fait
lagence fait exclusivement le travail en
vérifiant bien sûr la qualité du produit
et faire tenir tout ça dans une même
commission à mon sens se lève à la
démocratie lieu du propos et à son
efficacité vous seriez plutôt favorable
à une organisation du type de celle de
la vie où il ya douze commissions
consultatives
je crois que les commissions qui sont en
adobe par rapport aux sujets c'est ça
peut-être par par classe thérapeutique
ou par nous parler n'est rien pour les
génériques par exemple où la france a
beaucoup de retard que parce que je suis
d'accord avec vous la commission est
donc l hémisphère c'est donc elle est
accusée d'avoir des ordres du jour trop
chargé que les experts connaissent pas
c'est les dossiers en fait il est
connaissent mais les connaissent chacun
pour leur propre parti d' expertise et
examiner le changement de présentation
d'une boîte c'est très important
la réglementation prévoit que ça se
fasse en commission d'un mêmes
peut pas être la même commission dans
laquelle on réévalue la relation
bénéfice risque du médiator qui suppose
débat contradictoire d'experts pour ne
citer que cet exemple jugé l'âge d'or
deux questions alors la première comment
voyez vous l'avenir de la commission mm
par rapport à l' agence européenne avec
l' agence européenne dont les
laboratoires emprunte de plus en plus la
procédure centralisée
d'autant plus que quelquefois ils n'ont
pas le choix puisque pour certains
médicaments sont obligés de passer par
cette procédure
donc on peut imaginer qu'avec le temps
le travail en ce qui concerne les
molécules nouvelles de la commissione
les mêmes va diminuer on peut même
imaginer un jour que l'essentiel du
travail pour voir la totalité de des
autorisations de mise sur le marché soit
de la compétence de lagence de londres à
ce moment là le rôle de la commission
des mêmes de l'afssaps sera réduit à sa
plus simple expression alors
effectivement alors encore un rôle à
l'est les génériques peut-être certains
renouvellements et renouvellement
d'autorisation encore que non puisque ce
qui est centralisé y aura réellement
centralisée donc comment vous voyez
l'avenir de l'avenir du développement de
la commission des mêmes jeux
je vous pose cette question parce que
j'ai je vous ai peut-être pris
connaissance du rapport even qui
envisagent de fondre enfin tendue dans
une même agence à la commission d'un mm
et la commission de transparence alors
je voulais en même temps avoir votre
avis et la deuxième question concerne la
disons les rapports entre la commission
nationale de pharmacovigilance et la
commission d'aller même est ce que vous
êtes partis sens d'une plus grande
autonomie de la commission
pharmacovigilance est nécessaire que
lorsque la commission nationale de la
pharmacovigilance le prend et mais un
avis concernant un médicament soit sur
le retrait ce soit sur des effets déjà
en soi et soit obligé un pur de passer
par la commission m à mm pour évaluer
par exemple le la la balance bénéfice
risque ou bien est-ce que imaginons que
la commission quand ça s'est produit à
en 2000 je crois que c en 2100 2007 il y
avait divergentes entre la commission
d'ayem et la commission nationale de
pharmacovigilance à commission de 5 ou
10 ans voulait retirer le médiator là et
même nom à ce moment-là il y à un
conflit et le directeur général doit
être amené à arbitrer alors est-ce qu'
il serait pas plus simple de
d'autonomiser à la la commission de la
copie lens pour qu' elle n'est pas à son
avis n'est pas à transiter par la
commission d'amm et même pour qu'ensuite
le directeur général prenne sa décision
voilà deux guides notre travail mais la
responsabilité que nous avait donné
c'est d'examiner la relation bénéfice
risque avant la miction de marché au
moment là mis sur le marché dans la
suite la mission de marché donc il ya
pas les bons qui regardent le bénéfice
et les méchants qui regardent le risque
où les méchants qui regardent le risque
donc c'est un travail qui doit se faire
ensemble ils séparent avocat versus pro
du procureur c'est que par nature dans
tous les principes actifs
il ya des effets bénéfiques qui sont
recherchées mais il ya aussi des effets
nocifs qui sont donc c'est la base du
métier et imaginer qu'on puisse
dissocier ces deux aspects en prêt à et
même pendant la même voire en poste à
mêmes me paraît extrêmement dangereux
car rajoute
rajouterait à la confusion par rapport à
l'europe c'est plutôt favorable
d'ailleurs une collision une équipe à
une commission unique pharmacovigilance
elle qui est je ne peux pas me permettre
de tout autant de contre la
réglementation que je respecte plus mais
s'il c'est mon sentiment la réponse est
oui
lors de la prochaine réunion est dehors
de la précédente
les membres la commission de mais
honnêtement ça consiste à quoi faire ce
sont les mêmes experts tout de même payé
par de l'argent public quand ce sont des
personnes de l'agent ils sont à oui oui
d'accord mais pas des experts externes
en mémoire les évaluateurs de l'agent de
l'attaquant
d'accord ils sont bons il y en a qui
évalue le risque et d'autres qui évalue
le bénéfice bon tout ça c'est leur
boulot d'accord donc dissocier de
service qui regardent le bénéfice lot
qui regardent le risque me paraît un peu
dangereux en terme d'organisation et en
ce qui concerne des experts extérieurs
c'est un peu la même chose on peut
retrouver des gens qui de temps en temps
son dans le bénéfice de temps en temps
sans le risque
les expertises doit être contradictoire
par nature pour déterminer un ratio
finale qui est l' équilibre entre entre
le bénéfice et le risque
elle se fait avec des toxicologues il
suffit donc ça je crois que c'est
vraiment la base et elle existe et ça
existe à l'échelle mondiale ça commence
à être bien reconnu par contre est de
plus la surveillance du risque doit être
haussier associé à la surveillance du
bénéfice ça va de soi et le grand
changement qui se produit dès l'année
prochaine en europe
et c'est très bien qu'on est temps en
temps des directives sait que nous
devrons suivre les beurs les firmes
devront produire des documents sur les
bénéfices et les risques
au fil du temps sur leurs produits et
les agences dont l'afssaps auront la
responsabilité de corriger les documents
amenés par les firmes de les re
questionner
voire dans certains pays comme le nôtre
qui est un des plus généreux en termes
d'accès aux produits de santé de
corriger le tir qui est prévu par la
firme et par l'enregistrement
un exemple idiot le thalidomide est
indiqué dans le traitement des myélomes
après 61 ans
certes un dermatologue trouve que ça
serait intéressant de le donner aussi
dans des mets dans des maladies de la
peau peu compliqué et c'est donc
l'agencé européenne prend déjà un plan
de surveillance de risque la france peut
parfaitement dire nous ne voulons pas
prendre le risque qui est des jeunes
femmes exposées aux thalidomide est que
si la firme veut développer dans cette
branche là l acap préparer un dossier
haddock
car nous ne voulons pas voir un bébé
thalidomide en france donc ça c'est
permis
d'accord il suffit de le faire et donc
le fait que l'agencé européenne à
d'énormes avantages c'est que ça permet
de la confrontation dans l' expertise
publique la france contribue énormément
à l' agence européenne à plusieurs
niveaux d'abord à la merci des experts
internes de la sape
elle amène aussi les expertes des
groupes de travail dans certains
domaines
la france est très bien classé et donc
il n'y a pas d'opposition entre les deux
la commission dit à et même en france
effectivement doit pas être une chambre
d'enregistrement de l'europe et traiter
des sous dossiers
tous les dossiers sont importants en ce
qui concerne la procédure centralisée là
mêmes et quand même une procédure bien
sûr ce trop bien sûr d'encadrement mais
ça ne résout pas la vie du médicament eu
une vie avant avancer la france respire
des pgr supplémentaires mais il devient
avance et la france qui donnent
l'autorisation des cliniques pour ceux
qui sont réalisés sur le territoire
maintenant il n'y a pas d'accord que
celle de vision mais la loi pour elle
est d'accord avec moi donc tu es ma
concert non mais parce que j'ai rien
c'est juste pour voir si c'est sur le
rôle de la valeur
des beats dans le haut niveau sera
centralisée au niveau européen voilà il
faut savoir que effectivement on est
rapporteur ou co rapporteur sur une
vingtaine de dossiers sur une centaine
par an donc on n'est pas remis de la
troisième agence européenne troisièmes
quatrièmes ex-aequo au niveau des autres
agences européennes à prendre la plume
1 il a rédigé le rapport d'évaluation
dans les procédures centralisée donc là
c'est l'ensemble des équipes internes de
lagence des évaluateurs et uniquement
les agents les équipes internes qui
participe à l'évaluation du dossier qui
est un gros travail par exemple on parle
souvent de nombreuses procédures de
l'afssaps mais si vous voulez pour vingt
dossiers à peu près par an c'est chaque
dossier ces douze évaluateurs internes
quasiment qui travaillent toute l'année
sur le dossier donc là lagence l'afssaps
prend une part active
si vous voulez à l'évaluation de dothy
et ça n'est pas une chambre
d'enregistrement ça c'est juste là
dessus qu il est par ailleurs sur les
autres dossiers
juste je termine un juge si vous
permettez
sur les 80 autres dossiers qui passe au
niveau de l'europe en procédure
centralisée et bien là aussi nous sommes
membres évidemment de la commission pour
le médicaments à usage humain et on nous
dit même très souvent qu'on est ce la
france et souvent fait fait partie des
pays qui donne des objections majeures
qui pose beaucoup de questions donc même
lorsque nous ne sommes pas un rapporteur
ou co rapporteur sur les dossiers sur
des produits qui ont un intérêt
thérapeutique majeur est bien la saps
avec ces évaluateurs prend une part
active dans l'évaluation donc là ce
n'est pas une chance d'enregistrer ou
alors elle n'aurait que je voulais
préciser je suis mal exprimé en tout cas
je suis mal fait comprendre je voulais
je parlais de la commission à mêmes de
l'absinthe je parlais pas des
représentants de l'afssaps qui siège au
cpm h et qui joue un rôle effectivement
très important puisque tantôt en tant
que rapporteur tantôt en tant que
conseiller pour un pour un dossier qui
rapportait par un autre vers un autre
état je suis le kangoo mais c'était la
commission est même en tant que telle
celle qui est présidée par monsieur
vittecoq un bon alors c'est le monsieur
hitchcock ne va pas à londres donc lui
quand il quel est son rôle
lorsque dans la procédure centralisée
c'est ça que je voulais dire et là qu'il
se contente d'enregistrer n'ont même pas
non non c'est ça ne passe pas par la
commission à la sbm a elle même faisait
don il parce que l'autre c'est justement
la procédure si vous voulez la procédure
centralisée à la caractéristique de d2
permettre de donner un avis puisque le
chmp donne un avis l'agencé européenne
donne un avis ensuite c'est de la
commission après un processus de
comitologie maintenant qui passe par
strasbourg qui donne l'autorisation
d'apple est commercialisée dans les 27
états membres d'à côté j'aurais pu
appeler ensuite effectivement il peut y
avoir des interventions spécifiques dus
aux réglementations particulières
notamment ce qui concerne la publicité
ou d'autres réglementations spécifiques
et il y à tout le processus
ensuite d'accès aux marchés notamment
comportement qui lui passe effectivement
par d'autres instances donc la
commentant la commission des messieurs
la commission d'amm de l'afssaps peut
s'autosaisir d'amélie
oui paris qu' il estime que et il peut
d'ailleurs préféré un pgr complémenter
absolument voilà donc non mais ça
c'était donc ils aèrent et la commission
française à mon sens doit se saisir
beaucoup plus souvent des modalités
d'utilisation et de distribution des
produits enregistrés à l'intérieur de
notre pays puisque derrière la haie mais
n'y a pas que le marché via
l'utilisation par les personnes et donc
les circuits d'utilisation du
distribution sont sous notre
responsabilité et c'est la-dessus où
l'évolution vers une commission
examinerait le le bénéfice-risque de
façon récurrente aux raisons sens pour
veiller à ce qu'un bien de santé sa
distribution soit adapté pas uniquement
aux risques mais au bénéfice cannes à
temps la population d'un système de
santé je voudrais redire que nous notre
pays a le plus de bénéfices mais aussi
le plus de risques puisque chez nous les
produits de santé sont très rapidement
accessible c'est beaucoup plus facile
pour certains pays de la communauté
européenne
quand je participe qu'il n'utilise pas
les produits de santé qu'ils
enregistrent donc effectivement inhalons
- les bénéfices et moi les risques donc
c'est un changement radical qui est de
travailler plus pour la distribution du
bien de santé on va poser une question
sur la transparence dans laquelle je
voudrais répond bien évidemment puisque
c'est une si nous devons examiner le
bénéfice-risque de façon régulière
c'est un devoir sans ça on va laisser
passer des baisses de bénéfices et on va
laisser passer des montées de risques on
doit les examiner dans un contexte qui
est pas forcément un comparateur hit
parade entre les divers médicaments mais
s'il ya des médicaments qui tout d'un
coup sont beaucoup plus performant que
d'autres
on doit pouvoir dans l'examen du
bénéfice-risque dire bah celui-là est
d'un peu moins de bénéfices parce que
les temps ont changé c'est ce qui est le
cas chez eux sur les antidiabétiques
donc il est paradoxal qu à une
dissociation entre les deux c'est
paradoxal et c'est difficile à
comprendre qu'avec les mêmes données et
les mêmes experts extérieurs des
opinions éventuellement différentes
puissent être comprise puisque ça veut
pas dire ce sont deux choses différentes
les utilisateurs nage et russel a
incohérent bon je pense que c'est la
même responsabilité d'examiner le
bénéfice risque en ce qui concerne et
cela devrait être doit être indépendant
bien évidemment du financement et du
remboursement afin que des décisions
prises de distribution ne soient pas
influencés par des restrictions de
budgétaire mais c'est sur cette
appréciation que le financeur décidera
ou non ça c'est une décision donc
politique et de régulation de du système
de santé de savoir quelles valeurs il
donne ou non à ces produits
nous nous devons garantir que ce sont
les meilleurs produits qui sont rendus
disponibles et forcément en comparaison
interné en comparaison externe et ce
n'est pas stable au cours du temps car
bien évidemment nous sommes une agence
qui doit travailler sur un progrès
thérapeutique est ce qu on veut offrir
c'est les progrès thérapeutiques et
quand il ya un progrès thérapeutique
généralement ça étouffe des progrès des
produits récemment la chaise un rôle
crucial
je tiens à le dire sur le système de
santé car elle intègre pas que le
médicament mais le parcours
thérapeutique
il n'y a aucune agence du médicament
dans le nom que ça soit la vie etc
nous on regarde par exemple tel
médicament mais on nie pas le nombre de
cure que le doit avoir un traitement
anti-cancéreux d'accord et ça c'est de
la chaise qui donne le parcours et ça
change tout en termes de régulation ça
change tout en termes d'impact et ça on
change tout en cas de risque pour hisser
le nice qui fait ce travail mais il
s'intéresse pas aux comparateurs des
médicaments il s'intéresse à l'utilité
du site dans le système de santé du
partage des biens
par exemple il peut dire il ne faut
jamais la psychothérapie dans le cancer
de prostate
même si un médicament qui est
enregistrée bon oui il faut le faire que
dans 5 % d'écart bon ça c'est pas le
rôle d'une agence du médicament
un jour du médicament elle doit vérifier
que ce médicament dans le cancer de la
prostate a une bonne relation bénéfice
risque dans un contexte et son rôle
n'est pas de dire combien de qu on doit
faire et à quel groupe de population on
doit la vraie c'est ça c'est forcément
une autorité qui est indépendant du
médicament et qui regarde le bénéfice
global c'est le nike pour des raisons
économiques
parfois ça fait un débat public un
angleterre mais qui a un système de
santé une sociologie un peu différent
quoi qu'ils ont l'air de raleigh
ils ont moins de déficit que nous quand
même hein ça c'est une issue de madame
blindage je vous pardonne mais je vous
vouliez vous m'aviez demandé à paroles
excusez moi ça va obliger une petite
gymnastique de retour en arrière mais ce
serait ponctuelle entre eux je sais
c'est sur les commissions
vous nous avez dit l'évolution éthique
des protocoles etc vous avez dit les
conflits d'intérêts sont affichées mais
est-ce que des conséquences en sont
tirées d'exclusion de certains débats
des personnes ayant des liens
voilà oui je parle pas de l'époque du
médiateur je parle maintenant non
voilà c'est ça où il est deuxième chose
est ce que vous êtes favorable ou non à
une proposition du grenelle auquel vous
avez par ailleurs participé qui a été
voté par le parlement d'une instance
extérieure chargé de vérifier que les
agences respectent bien leurs protocoles
éthique en quelque sorte quoi
actualisation des conflits d'intérêts
etc
beaucoup de travaux sont en cours et sur
ce sujet et je crois qu'il est très
important toutes les agences financé par
l'état et quel que soit leur domaine d
expertise
un sport qui va devenir nationale est
dangereux et la contestation de
l'expertisé publique
donc nous nous levons nous prêter à ces
réglages je voudrais rajouter une forme
d' expertise que vous avez donc on a
soutenu ensemble dans le cadre du
grenelle et je sais que vous y êtes
attaché aussi celle expertise citoyenne
parce que les débats entre experts
pharmacologue c'est intéressant mais au
bout d'un moment il faut arrêter
et c'est très important qu'il y ait une
expertise citoyenne qui aident ou du
moins qui dote son regard voire même son
expertise aux états unis vous ne
l'ignorez pas il ya un gros mais dans
les agences
ce qu'on appelle les patientes advocacy
groupes qui sont des personnes formées
pour résister aux pressions des grands
savants aux pressions éventuellement des
parties prenantes aux pressions des
politiques et qui participe aux débats
qui sont capables de lire le dossier en
disant mais finalement c'est pas si
intéressant que ça pour les patients
donc je vais voter contre donc ça change
un peu la donne
alors je sais pas si on a près dans
l'intention j'ai vraiment l'intention
d'essayer de l'expérimenté en france par
contre le débat citoyen et déjà bien
organisé par ailleurs mais je crois
qu'on a tendance
lorsqu'on parle devant les citoyens les
experts ce ne peuvent pas avoir la même
voie et je crois qu'il faut pas mélanger
des citoyens et les parties prenantes
il est légitime il faut savoir que quand
on a une commission quand on examine
amène un médicament sur la mucoviscidose
il est normal que l'association de lutte
contre le mais qu ici deux soient
présentes mais à ce moment là elle est
partie prenante elle n'est pas notre
bien évidemment parce qu'elle est
voilà merci bien alors est justement
puisqu'on est revenue sur les experts
pensez vous qu'il faut sanctionner les
experts qui ne publient pas leurs liens
d'intérêts ou qui font de fausses
déclarations qui font des oublis ou etc
c'est à l'évidence une faute grave oui
puisque c'est une actuellement il ya
plus que 500 euros puisque c'est une
tromperie
je peux vous dire que dans la communauté
scientifique internationale
c'est certainement française au cinéma
international c'est une règle d'or
risque d'être mali complètement de la
communauté scientifique parce que ça
s'est déjà produit c'est toujours le
scond l'autre on a fait une déclaration
trompeuse et que la signer un article t
orienté sur un type de pratique c'est
une fois de très grave
bon lui il faut que tout le monde aussi
balai devant chez soi quand ce sont des
universitaires c'est important aussi que
la déontologie de l'université puisse
s'exercer parce qu'ils remettent en
question aussi la qualité des
anthologique 2
l'université donc la sanction oui je
crois qu'il faudra une sanction
je crois que vous avez fait aussi une
proposition importante la
démocratisation au sénat sous forme d'un
amendement qui rappellerait le sunshine
act
oui il est quand même très important qui
est aussi une des formes la
démocratisation aux états unis si les
gens sont payés il faut que ça se sache
et puis voilà quoi qu'en ait payé on est
payé puis y est quand on est payé c'est
à dire qu'on est vendu mais enfin c'est
important que tout le monde sache
parquet allait payer pour quoi faire
suivant mais je pense qu'il ya un
relatif consensus je dirais même les
laboratoires que nous avons interrogé le
lem que dante interrogées est favorable
à ce que soit rendue publique
les liens d'intérêts qu'il peut avoir
avec les médecins qui le siège
d'ailleurs à l'afssaps ou qui n'ai
aucune fonction dans aucune agence à ski
parce que effectivement ces médecins
aujourd'hui on connaît pas leurs liens
d'intérêts devraient donc il est
nécessaire
alors là j'ai appris à doser dit qu'on
avait quand même on est en avance sur
les états unis puisque eux ils n'ont pas
il n'est pas obligatoire pour les
laboratoires de publier et les liens
qu'ils ont avec les associations c'est
pas c'est pas alors que sur ce plan j'ai
été très étonné parce que je pensais que
on était très en retard par un parole
mais non il ne semble pas en tout cas je
pense que c'est dans cette voie qu'il
faut qu'il faut effectivement s'orienter
je dirais même et je pense que le
ministre l'a dit lui même je pense qu'il
faut il faut aussi je sais pas s'il est
vivant tout cas je pense que les
sociétés savantes doivent aussi aussi me
semble-t-il publier leurs liens
d'intérêts parce qu'on s'est aperçu que
sans les laboratoires
n'aurait pas de nora pas d'existence il
pourrait page et pour ça je m'interroge
me voyais là que la l'université
descartes faisait à un grand un grand
colloque oui sur la sur la démocratie
demain donc il n'ya pas de sponsors ils
arrivent à faire des colloques sans
l'industrie pharmaceutique
je sais pas comment ils y arrivent parce
que je les médecins sont incapables de
se rencontrer ou de faire dd des
colloques sans l'industrie dans la city
c'est ça qui est 7e art écoutez moi j'ai
j'ai rencontré beaucoup d'experts qui
ont dit mais si on est pour la faire
passer la nuit dans le sud on ne
pourrait pas nous rendre au congrès qui
qui est auquel nous devons participer
donc il y à il ya là effectivement un
problème une carence de l'état
deux remarques si vous permettez le
déclarer ça change tout il ya beaucoup
de congrès qui sont effectivement qu'ils
ne peuvent pas exister surtout à
l'échelle mondiale sans mention de
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est pas une
nouveauté bon c'est concret sont de plus
en plus mondiaux mais là aussi c'est une
déclaration d'intérêts on sait dans mon
champ de spécialité que lascaux par
exemple un grand congrès bon c'est un
congrès c'est un salon en fait un le
festival de cannes ya des sponsors aussi
comme le medec par exemple voilà il n'ya
pas donc c'est un salon et on présente
les nouveaux produits éventuellement la
bourse va monter ou descendre
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il ait pas d
une des sessions scientifiques
extrêmement puissante et de traits de
très bon niveau comme au festival de
cannes on peut trouver des oeuvres de
créateurs inconnus
donc c'est un peu ça commençait par la
sécu le festival de cannes
non non non mais lascaux d'ailleurs ces
pays parce que nous n'avons su ça
n'aurait aucun appui sur les voiles nous
n'avons aucune raison de penser il ya
quand même des cours publics cela relève
en plus bien avant que l'intérêt à
financer la participation à des grands
salons internationaux
d'accord
sur l'argent de la solidarité nationale
je suis dépité dacia entendent bien
parce que l'argent dont dispose de
laboratoires
il vient de chez vous c'est quand même
un peu l'argent public non parce que si
les médicaments n'étaient pas remboursés
par la sécurité sociale je pense qu' il
n'aurait pas autant de moyens pour
financer les nombreux colloques et la
publicité et la promotion des langues et
donc je crois qu'il faut pas se tromper
à ce que vous défendez que je partage
ses 1,2 v sincèrement donc on pourrait
très vite et qu'il faut qu'on soit très
clair sur les liens d'intérêts vous avez
mentionné les sociétés savantes en fait
que c'est quoi créer une société savante
s'est créé une association loi 1901
personne ne vérifie le caractère saveurs
de la société d'accord
donc on peut se proclamer sociétés
savantes sans forcément qui est une
règle qui soit admise et c'est peut-être
bien comme ça ensuite que les sociétés
savantes sollicite de l'argent public
pour exercer sa mission sa vente
pourquoi pas organiser des colloques
dans le cas de l'université je n'ai
peut-être pas totalement interdit donc
dans les déclarations que vous allez
demander aux firmes sur les fonds
qu'elles versent vous aurez aussi un
accès au déclarant à l'argent qu'elle
verse aux sociétés qui organise des
congrès à paris ou dans le monde j'ai
toujours et on aura alors l'occasion
peut-être de je crois que c'est
important que la transparence soit faite
donc les sociétés savantes peuvent vivre
avec de l'argent public
modestement ça peut venir dans ce qu'on
me dit que c'est rarement lituanie mais
ça peut venir c'est la nuit d'autant
plus que ce que je sache paris
l'apprendre première ville de conclure
monde oui pour l'instant j'essaie très
prisée pour les fonds c'est bon ça
paraît mais c'est quand même pas mal
il faut que tous ces liens soit en ce
qui concerne les fonctionnaires comme
moi ou comme les fonctionnaires de la
vie' il quand ils vont à lascaux il
s'exprime pas au nom de l'amitié il
reste à côté ils sont pas vite et c'est
comme ça c'est normal il n'y a pas de
liens d'intérêts qu'ils puissent être
par contre qui s'intéresse aux
communications scientifiques où la
veille étaient présentés dans ce type de
colloques
je crois que c'est un devoir comme
honnêtement
donc il faut limiter effectivement les
financements par l'industrie
pharmaceutique est financée de façon
beaucoup plus explicite des sociétés
savantes qui prennent des règles
déontologiques et n'accepte pas d'argent
de publicité bon synchro un gros travail
comme vous savez dans l'édition
scientifique
il ya un phénomène mondial qui est
magnifique qui s'appelle plos public
library of science
d'accord ou les plus grands
scientifiques du monde entier se sont
associés pour faire une ébauche une
revue totalement indépendante du
financement de l'industrie
pharmaceutique
donc ce n'est pas interdit pour les
collectes qui veulent publier un très
bon niveau
ils sont pas obligés de passer par des
revues sponsorisé par l'industrie
pharmaceutique pour que les clubs
l'éclairage en gros il faut que dans les
revues ou dans les congrès on sache qui
fait quoi et au nom de qui on parle
y a pas d'entente de dire je je suis
porte parole de tels chiens
pourquoi pas mais le tout c'est de le
dire qu'on trouve à toi de la pseudo
sénateurs
c'est plutôt une marque de qualité
et de vous connaissez normalement oui je
connais mon mariage je suis de marseille
est allé quelquefois en septembre je
serai une fois l'an et vous comptez y
retourner là maintenant vous n'êtes pas
ici en général si je si je vais à
lourmarin ces pourparlers pour essayer
de porter la sky a pas dans les huit le
sénat où la concertation pas si je serai
7x ok y'a pas y'a pas de problème mais
on n'est pas obligé d'avaler la cuisine
l'industrie pharmaceutique
on peut porter une voiture bien 2e
colloque centre et ils sont très forts à
sont de grands professionnels on n'a
même pas à madame je salue l'arrivée de
madame l'arpenteur que j'ai supplée
essayer de supplier tant bien que mal et
qui maintenant va pouvoir enfin vous
posez ces questions je vous en prie
shenzhen a taillé un deuxième colloque
important qui s'appelle bien le le
colloque de gien qui suit le colloque de
lourmarin qui se passe dans un si on
rate là on en a toujours l'autre pour se
rattraper
un bébé est financé par la salle c'est
par l'inserm et tous les chercheurs tous
les industriels aussi son présent
semblent ils mangent à la même cafétéria
et les choses peuvent se faire de façon
très vous n'invitez jamais par exemple
les industriels bien sûr ils viennent à
l'absinthe les colloques pour mai un
colloque qui sera organisé par l'afssaps
et bien sûr vous qui allez bien à
plaindre exemple madame bartoli oui oui
non juste un exemple un pour vous
comprends ce genre d'initiative à saint
denis
donc vous invitons dans nos locaux ont
fait très régulièrement par exemple une
journée portes ouvertes pour les pme
innovantes et pour on a fait également
dans une journée pour les académies
innovants et toutes les équipes
académiques justement qui font de la
recherche appliquée ou de la recherche
clinique dans le domaine des produits de
santé et l'a donc nous invitons c'est
absolument gratuits à se limite c'est
évidemment la place disponible à saint
denis ce n'est pas illimité
et quant à elle est donc là tout le
monde vient on les nourrit vous n'allez
pas d'aller dans les stations balnéaires
ou exotiques
heureusement très bon l'avant at war
c'est à saint denis ben non voilà on est
soucieux de préserver dépenses publiques
oui quand on a vu alors que pour les la
borne à cette fois ce ne sont pas des
buts sont pas d'effective en cd sont
libres devant leurs deux répondent de
leurs dépenses devant leurs actions oui
effectivement ça c'est un handicap
insurmontable bien alors madame la porte
puisque vous êtes là peut-être que vous
pourriez en profiter pour vous exprimer
je voudrais m'excuser commission des
affaires sociales sur le projet de loi
de bioéthique on était enfermé depuis
14h30
j'ai cru bon au sortir de cette réunion
de venir pour voir si la réunion était
vous étiez au début de cette réunion
monsieur président voir si cette réunion
était fini et d'abord m'excuser auprès
de directeurs de f sas des
fonctionnaires et mon collègue mais donc
je ne sais pas quelles sont les
questions qui a été posé simplement vous
le dis que la une qui n'a pas été posée
que j'aimerais bien posée est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire quelle est la
procédure habituelle de remonter
traitement de l'information entre
l'agent chargé du médicament et le
gouvernement sur les effets indésirables
de médicaments
c'est à dire vous dit
la pile à la direction j'ai pas ce que
certain nombre de ministres auditionnés
on dit on affirmé ne pas avoir été
informés sur le médiator et moi je
voudrais qu'on voudrait connaître la
procédure oui de remontée du traitement
d'informations entre l'agencé le
gouvernement
quant aux quelque part vous avez une
indication une suspicion des faits
d'effets indésirables de médicaments
alors déjà pour commencer si vous voulez
la direction générale de la santé
présente dans toutes les commissions qui
lui qui donc à la commission nationale
de pharmacovigilance par exemple la
commission d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché a connu son pubis et donc de ce
fait si vous voulez le représentant de
la direction générale de la santé donc
doit signaler est en tout cas est là
pour entendre il faire entendre
éventuellement sa voix dans ses
différents instance et est par ailleurs
lorsqu il y a un doute sur des
indications et bien l' agence a été
créée pour prendre des décisions au nom
de l'état et donc dans ce cas il y à des
informations si vous voulez qu'ils sont
donnés légèrement en amont sur les
tenants et les aboutissants des
décisions sensibles que l' agence doit
prendre mais effectivement elle est
tenue de par ses missions inscrit dans
la loi de prendre ses décisions au nom
de l'état
voilà pour les travaux de la mission
d'information sur le médiator
hier le sénat a adopté en seconde
lecture une proposition